double team he kicks it out Martini
thought about a shot Baseline pass and
that foul underneath
and it's going to send Kaden Pierce to
the free-throw line biggest two free
throws of this young man's life
[Applause]
Caden Pierce
ivy league rookie of the year
[Applause]
his dad Greg was a football player at
Norris weapon his mom was a star
volleyball player in Northwestern his
brothers still playing basketball
overseas he's got a brother that plays
wide receiver for the Colts can he be a
hero here
a 65 percent free-throw shooter just
buried the first one
[Applause]
that's a brother that plays for the
Colts I didn't know that
he's not my fantasy Dynasty team I sure
he is this guy's going to be on some
fantasy Dynasty team if he hits this
free throw and he does two free throws
for the 65 free throw shooter one
possession game
Arizona needs three to send this thing
to overtime you don't have to jack a
three though get a quick two if you can
15 seconds left Raymond one ball that's
not it air ball that's not it Ballo
tries to keep it alive
great shot no good
Ness
wow a woman foul on the rebound
some of the Arizona players beside
themselves Raymond who took that shot
just got off his knees to Bellis walking
up the court with his hands on his hips
if these free throws go
the Tigers
will prevail in a cat fight of their
life
[Applause]
Princeton an 8-0 run
hosan a Walmart
has not been to the line today
he only needs one but it's a one and one
65 free throw shooter
as Brendan said you only need one now if
you press it that's a good move get off
the line
get off the line play solid defense no
fouls on the three-point shot
a 15-point day
bertosan awoma
this would be the Capper
no good Arizona
with a prayer that will not go and the
Tigers of Princeton grow their way
[Applause]
into round two
as they upset the number two seed
Wildcats of Arizona
Princeton ended the first half on an 8-0
run they ended the game on a 9-0 run
wow it's March I've been shot
so are the Wildcats
[Music]
Arizona coming into this game averaging
over 80. only get it to 55 and I think
the biggest thing that shocked me was
Princeton was able to get this Victory
only shooting 425 from the three-point
line
only nine assists to 11 turnovers
Princeton didn't even play their best
basketball but yet we are here right now
so 27 years ago it was a win over UCLA
Pete Carrell now it's Mitch Henderson
who was the point guard on that team
it's his turn he's with Dana and the
star of the game guys thanks coach you
couldn't hear this but they were just
referencing Pete Carrillo and his huge
win and your point guard for Coach Grill
how does it feel to be the coach getting
a win like this with these guys we've
enjoyed the guys who have played with
the utility win for a long time and um
so these guys get that opportunity now
and uh they did it they that was a long
time ago but this group I mean we were
that whole game that was awesome I
thought it was going to be improbable
and they're so good Arizona I'm just so
proud of Towson and his teammates
I was telling us yesterday talking about
the composure that he wanted you all to
have to go out there and play your game
and play the style the way that you did
enjoying this moment toast on how are
you able to do that in the second half
yeah we have great confidence you know
we were we came in you know wanted to
get it done and we did we had full
confidence that we could and we executed
really well we had a great game plan
from the coach so that gives us
confidence to you know stay composed and
do what we need to do just get
moment
opening so yeah I think so it feels
great it feels great congratulations to
both of you thank you very much thank
you
what a win for the Princeton tigers
heartbreak for the Wildcats of Arizona
the tournament continues now on TBS with
Illinois and Arkansas and TNT has Auburn
in Iowa at 6 50 Eastern we'll send you
to our studio after these messages
Princeton